[Musique]
c'est la partie de toi que personne ne peut voir
mais tu sais qu'elle est là et moi aussi
c'est la partie de toi que personne ne peut
enlever
parce que c'est la partie de toi qui est
vraiment unique
tu vois ce que j'aime chez toi  n'est-ce pas
les trucs à l'extérieur
ce que j'aime chez toi, ce sont les autres trucs qui font
pipi à l'intérieur des trucs des
sourires ou des petits cadeaux qu'on se donne
c'est la plus belle partie de
vous-même
un gaucher parce que vous êtes une chatte s'il
vous plaît n'utilisez pas un mauvais  mot quand vous pouvez utiliser un
peu de travail
[Musique]
chaque douleur a besoin d'un nom qu'est-ce que nous pensons
que c'est la voiture
[Musique]
vous ne réduisez pas
une marque de confiance
[Applaudissements]
personne ne voit un homme
[Musique]
quelque chose de nouveau aujourd'hui quelque chose est
grandir en moi
[Musique] les
prochains invités élèvent ton fils ta fille
[Musique]
toi